getting a robot to fly is impressive but
once it's in the air how do you keep it
there without draining too much energy
nature's answer is perching think of
perching as landing without a runway
birds bats and insects do it they can
land on narrow surfaces upside down or
right side up remain idle for long
periods of time and then take off by
launching themselves from different
positions now researchers have made a
robotic insect that can perch by using
electro adhesion the tiny robot is
adorned with an electrode patch that can
create a static charge for attaching to
surfaces it's a similar principle to
static cling from a balloon this type of
adhesion is pretty weak so objects must
be really light for them to stick to a
surface to get around that limitation
scientists designed these robots to
weigh a miniscule 84 milligrams
that's less than a B at this weight it
takes a thousand times less power to
perch than to fly the lightweight
electrode patch combined with a flexible
shock absorbing mount enables the robot
to perch on a variety of surfaces glass
wood and even a leaf to detach the
electricity is turned off allowing the
patch to discharge once they can fly Ted
Alice these perching robots could be
used to provide Birds Eye views of
disaster areas detect hazardous
chemicals or enable communication in
remote regions future designs could
allow for perching on vertical surfaces
which means we could have our first
robotic fly on the wall